[Music]
okay everybody i
am so excited today because i get to
talk to
april bolby aka rita farr aka gertrude
kromp aka miss goopy aka elastigirl aka
alasta woman
april how are you doing today oh after
that introduction i'm doing
just fine thank you
it's exciting because you're actually
the first superhero i've gotten to
interview so i was thrilled that it was
you
i've just recently dipped into doom
patrol and i binged it the past two
weeks i fell in love with your
performance
so this is really exciting for me the
thing that really
man yeah and you know i i was wondering
when you take on a superhero role and
you there's pressures that come with
that
and getting it right the first time and
that's what impressed me about the whole
show and including your portrayal of
alaska woman is that
you guys got it right on the first notes
so can you just talk to me about the
process preparing for that to make sure
like was there
any portrayals in other media and tv
or film or movies that kind of inspired
your portrayal of rita far
yeah for sure look we got a very
exciting
treat which we got to do doom patrol
which has never been done before
so i went immediately to the silver
age comic books which is the original
doom patrol and then
got word that we were focusing more on
the grant morrison version
of the comic book so uh went to there
and
you know spoke with jeremy carver about
the character and
that she's this narcissistic you know
hollywood star but really
what she is is a broken human being
and that really informed the character
and
how to play it um and then from there
getting the bones of
you know the human condition inside of
rita and why she's so broken and why
she's so
you know hurtful to other people to
protect herself
and then i watched to get the behavior
and the mannerisms
a bunch of old movies like with betty
davis and
um you know i watched sunset boulevard i
watched a lot of twilight zone
um kind of inform her movements and her
voice and
the cadence in which she speaks so
that's interesting too because
i noticed there's like a little bit of a
mid-atlantic accent going on here
and you do it really well yeah and i
wonder do you
stay in that on set like is there method
acting to this or
are you able to knock in and out of that
accent
that's a great question i i am able to
knock in and out of it pretty quickly
but um boy if i didn't that would be
hilarious
i had to know if
so interesting you talk about too
because i think what people love about
rita is her
character arc from the beginning of
season one to midway through season two
which we've seen
and that you see she's so unlikable by
not
wanting an amputee camera operator on
her set and then to come full circle
where
she's literally saving larry's
great-grandson this season putting her
back in front of him and you're just
amazed how far she's coming how much
she's like
one of the most likable characters ever
on screen now so i wonder that
for you when you're in episode 6 now
your character rita she's
goes to this community theater and she
meets isabella who's playing her
in the play and she says all this nasty
stuff about her as the backstory for her
like needy
attention seeking wants her mother's
acceptance she's hideous inside out
did you as an actress as april
do a kind of backstory for rita like
isabella was saying if that makes any
sense to you
yes um i think throughout the two
seasons
i've been lucky enough to be informed
every episode
more and more of rita's backstory so
um when isabella is repeating it it
it really is like because of rita's
very colorful history that i can
place the images and witchy fame into
uh my performance because that she
essentially is repeating reach's
backstory which is what's
so disturbing about that theme that
there's this little
bratty actress telling rita who she
is and and she's right and that's why
she at the end she's looking for answers
and she's like well
who who am i who am i supposed to be and
then of course that's the comedy comes
in and she's like oh you're a person who
destroys the world and
once again rita's heart is broken you're
right so what what do you think though
where we are in season two what do you
think rita's draw at this point was to
go
audition for this community theater and
kind of can you elaborate a little bit
about like
where larry even is like hinting towards
her where it's not just about the fame
for her anymore and maybe where her
mindset is on that with acting
um yeah i think that she i think that
rita is just looking for purpose
and i think she's finding more
confidence like she's getting out of the
house this season she's
she's trying to be of service
even though she doesn't quite know where
she belongs yet so i think it is
less about her
need to be seen and more that she she
wants to prove
that she's worthy of something that she
that she
she deserves to be on stage she deserves
to um
she wins this role all on her own
without her mother's influence and
um that she can you know contribute
and i i think that's the evolution for
our rita this season as well and um
being able you know to heal through that
so i do think she
enjoyed the the you know the
uh whatever that is i'm like oh this is
the
light you know the um limelight
interface yeah
spotlight that's the word yes and and
it's good because it
it's awesome because it's such a
complicated character and you play all
the notes so well so consistently
and i wonder when mr nobody in
particular
haunts these different characters of
doom patrol with things of their past
their skeletons and
what's really good about the show is
that like you guys are always hinting at
things that we as the audience members
still don't know
and that includes rita and what i'm
wondering is you as the actress
do you even go and read the comics a
little more to know
some of those answers or or do you feel
like you don't even need to know those
things yet
when you're portraying her or do you
know them you know what i mean yeah um
i think i go to the comics to see um
the base of the story lines like what
kind of world do we live in what's the
craziest thing that can happen to the
doom patrol and that
helps to you know inform the
realism of it and then i think
you go into yourself a little bit
and just create the world for your
wounded character
so um you know the scripts inform that a
lot
which is very helpful the directors and
the cast members too like it's all about
their relationship and i think that's
just like the bones of
acting right like who are you in the
scene with what do you want out of the
scene
um so so that's that's the root i think
for her
so you say that too and it seems like
you're hinting at a little bit of like
you know the just personal parts of it
to you as a person so
i wonder how much of april is in rita
far do you relate
at points to the character oh my gosh
yes
you know i think uh rita is looking for
love
and she's um trying to
prove herself and she's kind of
suffering from
imposter syndrome and and i think that
on a certain level everyone experiences
that in life trying to
be a part of society trying to fit in
trying to
not mess up you know um trying to be
loved and
and moving forward with that so i
i do feel very much connected
to her because i i feel like that that
is you know
and everyone somehow has been wronged in
their life and
and has passed experiences and traumas
that
shape them and um i think
what's not more relatable than that yeah
no you're you're absolutely right it's
just it's
really cool to see you pull this off and
and what's interesting too about rita is
maybe
crazy jane gets to play all the
different personalities but i think what
a lot of people love watching about your
character is all the awesome outfits you
get to wear and these
1950s different stylings so i was
wondering for you
as an actress do you like get excited
when you meet with like the costume
designers or what you're gonna wear and
do you have say in what maybe you wear
for an outfit and maybe how it relates
to
rita's character right um yes
i get so excited it's so much fun to
walk into fittings
and see what they pull and they have
racks you know racks of like
okay and this scene she's gonna wear a
flowery dress and i'm like
that one that one that one and and we
they're just such stunning pieces that
really you can't go wrong
and i think what it comes down to is
comfortability or something if the theme
requires that i'm like running
and we're like can we wear flasks in
this uh this outfit okay
let's do that um but yeah it's it's such
a colorful process and i feel like it
informs
you know rita's body language and so
much and her behavior like when she gets
a scarf like look out she'll twiddle it
you know like it's just a lot of fun
yeah and i'm interested to know too you
are a veteran actor you have been at
this
uh and it shows so having this be a huge
role you land is there anything in your
trajectory as an actress that you feel
like prepared you for this that you're
like okay now i kind of see
what led me to this right i feel like
there's
always like little secret notes from the
universe that
kind of like show that you're on the
right path and i think if you if you
just see
if you look for them you'll see them so
there's been lots of fun
synchronicity i feel like life
experience in general
is very helpful to inform a character
but i do feel like um there's like let's
put the little easter eggs i
i don't know they come and they go
quickly but i can't
tell you one specific or another but i
do feel
like it's been a lovely journey and it
just
kind of keeps getting better do you have
any advice then for
actresses or actors that are feel like
they've been doing it for a while and
haven't landed that big dream role yet
and
for you getting it now like is there
something you can give them for people
in the headspace that might feel like
just quitting oh
yeah don't quit if you love it
continue i feel like we
as artists have such a important part to
play
especially now um that it's really
important to
be able to embrace
the art of acting so make every role
the role you know what you know what i
mean like it doesn't have to
mean something it's it's the emotional
work that you give to it and i feel like
that is our purpose whether you book the
job or not like
auditions i go into auditions and i'm
like
i i did it like whether the job is for
me or not
i gave them what was
unique to me so that is a very um
you know inspiring thing to walk away
with because it really it's not about
booking it's about like what did you how
did you serve the role and
then the job is just the icing on the
cake so don't quit because
there's there's always there will always
be more opportunities
you know i love that there's many people
who just heard that and are getting out
of bed and they're ready to go now
because of you yay and before i let you
go
i have to ask uh you have this podcast
you do
75 reads where you read david bowie's
favorite
books to try to understand david bowie
can you explain this podcast to me and
and how it's starting like kind of like
what goes on
oh man so my friend joe bozarth and i
are huge bowie fans and
we just discovered he had a 75
read list like he literally we were like
david's fully published
reading list and so we were thinking
how great it would be to um do a podcast
and then just
that would give us an excuse to read all
75 books and kind of
flirt and you know play in the world of
bowie and
try to decipher what he learned from the
books and where that showed up in his
music
so that's what we do so if you
are a book person it's like a podcast
book club so
we just kind of grab a book on the list
and then we read it and then we talk
about it and you guys are invited to
read them too
and talk about it as well that's amazing
everyone listening check out that
podcast 75 reads
and of course while you're at it if you
haven't caught up on doom patrol it is
on hbo max now and of course it's on the
dc
universe app it's exciting that it's on
hbo now more people are seeing it it's
getting huge exposure and so many people
are loving it
and i think it's really awesome to watch
you as a character it's
it's such an exciting thing to see it's
an original take on a superhero
and you're absolutely blowing everybody
away including myself
thank you so much april for joining uh
and i hope to talk to you again soon
me too thank you so much be well